with the hawk spent time on the G League
and he had weight issues vice past the
club for the G the what time warns the
thought he was fouled James in a belay
advice pass again and it's Davis this
time building that chemistry early mice
passport care about the Lakers screen is
off on a three pack top five McKee Steph
woollen here's that le you from lebra
they have 14 new players on their roster
here's James with the hard drive account
so right wrist this is what he does he
loves and embraces the contact mr. hit
is but his event is coming at you full
estate Alfonso my kitty was only fitting
the first three in this building comes
from Steph Curry
JaVale McGee taking advantage of the
lack of height of a Brooklyn pets pass
broken up recovered by Rondo adjust come
on here's green this time not a little
hip two three
Davis's right there there's that height
difference you were talking about being
here offensive rebound opportunity here
using that size and strength and finish
the little things on this Lakers team
what no getting inside all the beautiful
what for Davis so Anthony Davis able to
put it down Marquess of crisp side just
the other day
firstly the first off in line Sacramento
and the Laker onslaught continues
chemistry is already on point first
quarter the beautiful post up and for
those of you out there how he signaled
that was a raise of the eyebrow
possession Toit Daniels seventieth man
from Virginia Commonwealth is checked in
as Rondo sets it up here's Howard and
it's put down by Davis doesn't even take
a phone call from Magic to LA kids you
know and goes to the Clipper it's real
olefrog James taking to the rim ends up
on top of the campervan as he drew the
foul by the way this is his 17th NBA
season okay
for first round pick of the Atlanta
Hawks last season two years ago he was
the Big East Freshman of the year and
helped lead J right hand of subtly is
that possible is this possible as we see
them seven-point lead for the Lakers
Davis gonna draw the foul
[Applause]
move on drape on clue by Davis that's a
good call as I say are you all right are
you gonna are you gonna use your
challenge on Oh Harris moves without the
ball as well as anybody in the NBA name
is Pat Dorner Rondo then the feed by
Anthony Davis download oh we're on dicks
from behind the arc here were the first
quarter beautiful delivery by Dinwiddie
again a little Drive in giraffe Ron
James answering right back for the three
of his old NBA shanghaied game 2019
backdoor Avery Bradley off the feed from
LeBron James in the Lakers of the six
point lead
Corino Atem caps draw with you LeBron
James leads the way with 14 points his
tough fadeaway right there gives him 16
Lakers lead by four his activity honors
light Davis strolls down Anthony Davis
connects he's got 12
LeBron feeds downloaded Davis three for
cheating Davis on a spin out to the rim
and Anthony Davis with the two-hand
flush on the finish
to the rim what a fantastic driving
bucket here it is in transition LeBrons
ability and he looks ready to go
Spencer Dinwiddie working against Avery
Bradley nice feed inside rejection by FA
Davis that's one for five a cyclone gets
the spin to go in the brown hair with
the spin moves and you're just never
surprised at everything he can do i
david the Oise checked in brooklyn that
shot rejected by Anthony Davis there is
the beauty of Davis defensively the
bronze bolt goes into the rim scoring
but this is rel to start a game
excellent execution Roy Williams a smile
at door speaking of a great pass LeBron
James finding Katie Green final seconds
Caruso three is good at the board that's
gonna be the big concern it's not about
LeBron James and Anthony Davis as a
tandem as you see the
is about both of those guys remaining
Helms with the rebound seventeenth year
for LeBron he'll turn 35 at the end of
the summer he just pulleys press all the
way to the basket that time that's a
tough one Kuzma still out with an ankle
injury here's Davis the lock to the game
robe on James they play him as a score
willingly gives up the rock and the
confined shooters on the floor he's a
bright spot early on this season for
them preseason
what pass by James and the Slam by Davis
Larry Bird ability this guy is top 10
all-time they climb into cha when it's
all set and then he's gonna be top five
all-time his body of work is ability to
see the floor had as much time off as he
did to overcome that injury Wow about
that much Davis there for the follow
extinct but again just an amazing look
those of another dunk dominant guy that
he's going to be able to truly cheer on
James 3 assists 2 points 6 points for
Miggy 5 for Davis to go with 4 rebounds
another terrific look by Levon to a
cutting Avery Bradley Ron James already
as the Lakers up big give you a Clippers
home game and then the Lakers will play
their next three and official home games
against Utah Charlotte and Memphis James
at transaction with a spin on Lee and
the finish
defense sprinting back where he sees a
wall did you give them any lean on any
gap is a recipe for disaster
good night she can't be in the truck
five guys have to be sprinted out a
three-second difference in the clocks
here's Davis shakes the defenders spins
and I Freight dick Karissa
prior to that was the last to repeat his
MVP James actually did it twice rosanell
we you just white Howard the ability to
make a play dive to the hoop James being
defended by Eric Haskell rookie out of
Villanova James on the spin connect
that's eight fella Braun a couple of
minutes he's decided to play a little
one-on-one and be more aggressive and
results games going right back to back
and down
Haskell
and again tips to follow away getting
the friendly bounce that time doll
picking and choosing when he's gonna
look to make plays and when he's gonna
carry the team offense 23 okay give it
up at some point you got to take the
trip to the DMV I didn't have monitor my
three years
they got Davis Howard and James all on
the floor together here with green and
caldwell-pope LeBron is going to take
the deep three and his first trip will
try on tonight he's successful coach
hoop it around the disciple of the great
Rick Pitino he's more than qualified to
do the job James back and finish kissing
it off the glass and defense we give
them an angle turns the corner where's
the help you help late there's a price
to pay gets all the way to the cup for
the easy layin
warriors open the regular season a week
from tomorrow against the Clippers at
the brand-new Chase Center in San
Francisco Harris McGee from Davis five
assists for Anthony Davis now he
basically had because he played for him
and you guys have worked together for 15
years with Mike Breen on the finals it
stated a story like half your life
hasn't been spent
LeBron James let's stop that he's a he's
an outstanding young player with an
incredible future and I love ways that
right now we've seen one LeBron James in
the history of this game the ability to
rebound and initiate the offense and
make a play pass pick James over the
head with the left
as he's falling at about ten green pays
it off from three-point range
only one guy that's been LeBron James
what a spectacular play that's a small
fold playing the point guard position
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content